[Applauso]
[Musica]
Grazie buongiorno a tutti
organizzazione Balance
quello che vedete alle mie spalle può
essere visto come un insieme di oggetti
indistinti
sta lì possono essere delle persone
Ma se questi oggetti diventano
interdipendenti quindi collegati gli uni
con gli altri
e cominciano a prender vita pensate alle
persone che cominciano a svolgere delle
attività Allora questo sistema diventa
complesso
le organizzazioni sono sistemi complessi
sono fatte da persone che devono
raggiungere degli obiettivi
come tanti altri sistemi complessi Le
organizzazioni fatte da persone che
devono raggiungere degli obiettivi
tendono inevitabilmente verso il caos
l'entropia
Superata una certa soglia dimensionale
l'ordine lascia posto al disordine
non c'è Balance
c'è tanta vitalità ma non c'è Balance
non c'è equilibrio
o se si trova un equilibrio un
equilibrio puntuale
istantaneo temporaneo
da secoli Quindi le persone coinvolte
all'interno dell'organizzazione hanno
provato a dare un ordine
detto anche struttura struttura vuol
dire chi fa cosa vuol dire darsi delle
regole
possiamo vederla come una scacchiera ci
sono delle persone che sono legittimate
a muovere pedine su una scacchiera
Questa è la definizione tradizionale di
organizzazione strutturata
c'è Balance è un Balance statico e cioè
se fronteggiamo un mondo che si presenta
con regolarità
che ci pone delle sfide per le quali
abbiamo già delle soluzioni ho una bozza
di soluzione
questa forma di organizzazione ci
consente di essere efficienti ed
efficaci
Quindi c'è un Balance ma è statico
Le organizzazioni moderne
e la pandemia come 19 è un esempio
emblematico da questo punto di vista
sono invece esposte a Sfide che sono
molto più incerte e molto più complesse
e molto più ambigue e come vedremo molto
più volatili
e quindi le organizzazioni moderne non
possono accontentarsi di un Balance
statico devono andare alla ricerca di un
Balance dinamico
non è facile Facciamo un passo indietro
uno dei pilastri dell'organizzare
tradizionale il concetto di gerarchia
si possono dare degli ordini si possono
dare delle indicazioni si possono
allocare le risorse si decide chi fa
cosa e quando abbiamo delle soluzioni
possiamo metabolizzarla in qualcosa che
chiamiamo regole o procedure o
protocolli o processi delle
organizzazioni ma di nuovo
sono soluzioni note a problemi noti
Quindi finché il mondo si presenta in
maniera regolare e qui siamo alla
seconda rivoluzione industriale
strutturare l'organizzazione anche
facendo leva sulla gerarchia può essere
efficiente ed efficace ma non è l'unico
modo di organizzare questo modo detto
top down o meccanicistico
dell'organizzazione un altro modo è
questo e facciamo ben più di un passo
indietro questa è una bottega
rinascimentale
la bottega rinascimentale è un mondo
affascinante potremmo equipararla ad una
piccola impresa gestione familiare in
termini moderni cosa succedeva nella
bottega rinascimentale il titolare il
maestro
si interfacciava con i committenti
potremmo definirlo in termini di un
project manager
selezionava degli allievi attenzione non
dava loro degli ordini
trasmetteva loro un mestiere un'arte
condivideva quella che in termini
moderni chiameremo conoscenza
e creava
posto il problema cercava assieme agli
allievi la soluzione e le variazioni
richieste dai committenti In termini di
dimensioni personaggi delle opere colori
sfondi eccetera veniva
orchestrato nella sua nella ricerca
della soluzione
Quindi abbiamo due modelli di
riferimento l'organizzazione top down
che abbiamo visto in precedenza è una
forma di organizzazione che in termini
più moderni potremmo definire
bottom up
auto organizzazione empowerment possiamo
trovare tanti termini moderni per
visualizzare questo tipo di
organizzazione
Balance quale scegliamo come scegliamo
perché scegliamo
ora
Le organizzazioni tradizionali Quindi
quelle meccanicistiche fanno leva su un
concetto cardine delle scelte economiche
il concetto di trade off scelta
obbligata Quindi se lo vediamo nel
linguaggio di Alice nel paese delle
meraviglie che insegue il Bianconiglio
pillola Rossa pillola blu con linguaggio
di Matrix morpheus che chiede a Neo vuoi
rimanere nella realtà attuale o vuoi
tornare dove stavi prima
pillola Rossa pillola blu Trade off non
è Balance e quando di più in Balance
possa esistere perché è una scelta
esclude l'altra
quindi
innovazione o tradizione
profitto o sostenibilità ambientale
Cooperazione o competizione Open
Innovation quindi apertura della formula
di innovazione o chiusura difesa della
proprietà intellettuale e possiamo
citarne tantissimi di queste scelte Le
organizzazioni tradizionali
hanno assorbito nel loro modus operandi
il paradigma del trade-off sei obbligato
a scegliere in Balance squilibrio scegli
e Sei condizionato
Le organizzazioni moderne Tuttavia
fronteggiano un mondo
che volatile
incerto complesso ambiguo vuka
nell'acronimo anglosassone
se la realtà che fronteggiamo è volatile
quindi presenta delle eccessive
variazioni
incerta complessa ambigua
più mettiamo in scena la nostra
organizzazione meccanicistica quella
basata sulle regole sui protocolli sulla
gerarchia e più ci allontaniamo dalla
soluzione
l'organizzazione svela le sue derive più
burocratiche
cade nella frustrazione diventa goffa a
volte nel voler ripetere
protocolli che sono stati sviluppati in
un contesto di certezza quando
l'ambiente che Deve fronteggiare è
assolutamente incerto complesso volatile
ambiguo
qui si ferma la scienza
dell'organizzazione ciò che sappiamo è
che abbiamo empiricamente dimostrato
essere valido qui però comincia la
frontiera dell'organizzazione o meglio
dell'organizzare perché
ci sono bloccato Ecco qua scusate
guardate lo sfondo di questo palazzo
richiama una delle metamorfosi di Escher
se noi guardiamo la parte bassa troviamo
una scacchiera una struttura regolare
Se guardiamo a una parte alta vediamo
delle forme che
ci ricordano degli animali
Se guardiamo la stessa immagine da
destra verso sinistra Da sinistra verso
destra troviamo cose diverse oggetti
diversi colori diversi orientamenti
diversi Le organizzazioni moderne Quindi
devono passare da un paradigma basato su
Trade off scelta obbligata ad un
paradigma che si basa sul concetto di
paradosso ora nei paradossi ci sono due
o più forze
antitetiche
interconnesse durevole nel tempo
e quindi rispetto alla scelta se essere
profittevoli
o sostenibili
cooperativi o competitivi aperti o
chiusi
abbracciare un paradigma orientato al
paradosso significa che l'organizzazione
moderne ed è questo quello che sta
succedendo devono essere
contemporaneamente
boots and sia sia sia sia
efficienti che efficaci
sia aperte all'innovazione che Custodi
della loro tradizione
Come si fa Balance occorre trovare una
soluzione di equilibrio non più statico
ma dinamico quindi
Facciamo un passo indietro
Siamo partiti da alcuni elementi
dell'organizzazione li abbiamo animati
animandoli abbiamo trovato il caos
per risolvere il problema del caos
abbiamo realizzato una struttura una
scacchiera
Le organizzazioni moderne devono
bilanciare queste due istanze sfidando
degli ossimori
caos
ordinato ordine caotico
Le organizzazioni moderne sono queste
devono essere queste caleidoscopi
perché nei caleidoscopi abbiamo segmenti
noti
regole gerarchia procedure know how
che nel caos trovano nuovi equilibri
Balance
d'altronde
al paradosso
dal top down alla combinazione di top
down e Bottom
dalla tradizione
all'innovazione che si combinano in
maniera dinamica
Le organizzazioni caleidoscopiche non
inseguono l'equilibrio
sono il frutto dell'equilibrio
Grazie